[Musique]
c'est la première enseigne à inaugurer
la mutation de Skywest ce nouvel espace
d'escalade a ouvert le 17 décembre
dernier avec différentes activités tout
public il y a des niveaux de difficultés
donc pour les tout-petits il y a des
petits parcours adapté à l'orage et puis
après les plus téméraires pourront aller
jusqu'à 10 mètres 11 m de haut mais le
gros du chantier actuellement c'est pour
l'ouverture mi-janvier d'un espace de
loisirs sur deux étages bowling billard
karaoké et même un karting électrique
c'est quelque chose de
d'unique dans un centre commercial avec
en particulier du karting électrique qui
passera quand vous le verrez tout à
l'heure dans dans le mail en plein
centre et en plein milieu des visiteurs
ces nouvelles enseignes s'inscrivent
dans la stratégie du nouveau
propriétaire la société des grands
magasins a racheté le centre Skywest en
mai 2020 on a démoli tous les niveaux
inférieurs qui étaient fermés depuis de
nombreuses années donc on en a profité
pour tout raser et on a étudié tous les
différents projets pour aboutir un gros
parc de loisirs qu'on va installer et
qu'on va ouvrir sur cette fin d'année
2022 et début d'année 2023 en fait
l'idée c'est à partir du mois de janvier
nous aurons une ouverture par mois donc
speed Park
le trampoline Park
et derrière une surprise et les
discussions sont toujours en cours les
ouvertures se succéderont durant le
premier semestre 2023 un renouveau qui
arrive près de 20 ans après son
inauguration en 2005